insulin and glucagon are two peptide
hormones that are essential to the
metabolism of glycogen both hormones are
synthesized in the pancreas let's look
at them in depth insulin is a tiny
protein maybe beta cells due to its
small size the body has trouble creating
a stable insulin molecule to solve this
problem the protein is initially
synthesized as proinsulin and then
modified to create a molecule with a
hydrophobic amino acid court and a
charged amino acid surface with three
disulfide bridges after a meal blood
sugar levels rise and insulin is
released an order to remove sugar from
the blood insulin binds asymmetrically
to the surface of tyrosine kinase
receptors in liver muscles and fat cells
insulin causes the two chains of the
transmembrane receptor to phosphorylate
each other and signaling molecules this
signal tells the cell to take sugar from
the blood and stored as glycogen the
glucagon protein is a short alpha helix
with 29 amino acids it is synthesized by
alpha cells glucagon raises the
concentration of glucose in the
bloodstream through a process called
glycogenolysis in the liver it also
deactivates glycolysis in the liver
glucagon binds to its receptors in the
liver and kidneys the glucagon receptor
is a modified g-protein coupled receptor
consisting of seven alpha helixes the
receptor has a transmembrane domain as
well as an additional extracellular
domain this domain finds glucagon and
traps it by binding to one end of the
helix and delivering the other end to
the transmembrane domain this activates
the signaling pathway consisting of
adenylyl cyclase and cyclic AMP E and
the protein kinase phosphorylation chain
insulin deficiency or a failure to
activate the insulin signaling pathway
lead to serious problems that affect
nearly 29 million people in the u.s.
early onset diabetes can occur when
insulin function is impaired which can
be due to the body no longer producing
insulin due to damage to the pancreas or
age this can lead to blindness kidney
failure heart disease stroke loss of
limbs dehydration and pH changes so how
do you know if you're at risk for type 2
diabetes while being overweight or
having a family history of the illness
increases your risk ways of managing
diabetes risk include exercising and
eating healthy to maintain a healthy
weight and healthy body get your blood
sugar tested by a physician to know your
status thank you